so the demand for david pakman show
bumper stickers has exploded and a ton
of it has to do hillarious li with
covering up Alex Jones Infowars bumper
stickers not only in the United States
but around the world and it all started
because Ryan in Rochester New York wrote
in and said that he drives by an
Infowars bumper sticker on an electrical
transformer on the way to work every day
and could I send him of david pakman
show bumper-sticker and he will cover up
the Infowars bumper sticker and he did
we can put the picture back up this is
Ryan who covered up the Infowars bumper
sticker with a david pakman show bumper
sticker and this caused a huge influx of
bumper stickers to be purchased people
all over the US and in Canada and I
think in Europe are also planning to
cover up other Infowars bumper stickers
and send in pictures to the point where
we actually ran out of stickers last
week but I have a fresh new supply of
both the black and white david pakman
show bumper stickers and that's why I
come to you today to announce if I may
that we are going to be giving out free
bumper stickers to anyone who gets a new
yearly membership that's the only rule
you got to get a new yearly membership
we are also launching a new coupon code
so you can get a big Lea discount on
those yearly memberships and that coupon
code is vote soon 18 we've retired
I voted 17 I feel like it's been long
enough we're retiring I voted 17 the new
coupon code is vote soon 18 all one word
all lowercase that will give you a 40%
discount off of the membership of your
choice whether you pay full price or use
the discount code you can get a free
bumper sticker we will mail it to you
anywhere in the world okay I don't care
where you are in the world you get a new
yearly membership we will mail you a
free bumper sticker when you do that if
you remember currently fear not if
you're currently a monthly member you
can get the free sticker by converting
to a yearly membership and you can do it
at full price or you can do it at the
40% discount with the coupon code vote
soon 18 if you currently have a year
membership you can restart your
membership and get the free sticker as
well although if you're in that
situation it's probably cheaper just to
buy a bumper sticker at david pakman.com
slash gear we are going to be featuring
on the program
clever bumper sticker applications I
think is what I would call them on
upcoming shows and I know that a bunch
of people already have projects for
using the bumper sticker to cover up
something else which I think some of
them are gonna be hilarious and this is
important how to actually get the
sticker once you get your new yearly
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership reply to the new member email
when you sign up you get an email and
automated email that says you've done it
you've subscribed reply to that which
should go right to me david at david
pakman.com and say hey david i would
like the black bumper sticker or I would
like the white bumper sticker sticker
there are two versions and tell me your
address ok and then we will get those
bumper stickers out to you within 24 to
48 hours the dream scenario for me is to
have to order another batch of 200 each
200 black and 200 white bumper stickers
within like 10 days that would be
estimate amazing I'm very big on this
initiative and you know that I'm not
driving right now cuz I live in the city
and I definitely need a car yeah go
about buying a car just like just so you
can oh yeah I was gonna say go buy a car
just so you can put the bumper sticker
on there and listen if you want to put
it on your macbook pro or on your
backpack you've got a Herschel backpack
I know those are big with our audience
or whatever electrical transformer
disclaimer I do not endorse or condone
any vandalism check local laws before
you apply a bumper sticker anywhere and
do not be a criminal I think it's
important to make that disclaimer some
laws were okay with you breaking but not
vandalism and I certainly wouldn't
mention which ones I'm okay with people
breaking so that's it
new yearly membership you'll get a free
bumper sticker after you sign up email
me and if you want a 40% discount use
the coupon code vote soon 18 all one
word all lowercase